You have to protect him.
All this horror has come to my family all because I couldn't love a motherless child.
You are a Stark. You might not have my name, you have my blood.
Hey everybody, its charlie
We got our first official Game of Thrones Season 8 teaser trailer and an official release date which is way earlier than I expected
So we got to break it down
there's a new round of that Song of Ice and Fire book giveaway going on - all you have to do to enter is be
A subscriber and leave your favorite moment from the trailer on the video the big thing going on here mostly a lot of imagery
I don't know if any of these scenes actually happened during the episodes
But they will probably visit the crypts sometime in the first couple of episodes
But obviously most of that first scene is them arriving like Robert Baratheon arrived in the pilot episode
There's also another really big Easter egg in here for the pilot episode when Robert Baratheon and Ned Stark were walking through the crypts to
Go to Liana's statue. So if you don't remember, they're really mirroring the long walk promo that we got last year
It was sort of like the first big teaser with John Daenerys and Cersei each walking to their Thrones
but obviously this is
focusing mostly on the Starks at Winterfell because that's what we're gonna be when the season picks up and there's a lot of
heavy-handed
Foreshadowing about them dealing with John's Targaryen heritage in what his internal struggle is going to be over his true identity
Am I a Targaryen? Am I a stark of Winterfell?
So John walks past his mother Lyanna stark in the feather floats down. It's a tropical bird feather
The big easter egg is is this is the feather that Robert Baratheon?
Brought to her tomb when he arrived and they went down to visit
There was the whole reason for them going to the crypts
It was actually kind of a funny scene when you think about it in retrospect because they arrived had the formal
Introduction and then he basically told Cersei to screw off because he was going to the crypts
Before he did anything else to visit his long-lost loved who had died, but remember at this point
We didn't know anything about the truth of Robert's rebellion in Rhaegar Targaryen and Lyanna Stark
So they're walking through the crypts and he puts a tropical bird feather like he's basically leaving something special for the woman that he loved
Then later Dan and Dave had a special quote about trying to bring that moment back bring the feather back
They said the last time we saw the Statue of Lyanna was in the pilot episode
King Robert Baratheon laid this exotic tropical bird feather in her hand and we were preparing for the scene
We with Sansa that the feathers probably still there people haven't been going down there and cleaning up much
Certainly after Ramsay destroyed Winterfell there hasn't been any kind of janitorial crew going down and vacuuming
So they just thought that it would be a really cool easter egg for the pilot episode in that original
moment that the feather is still there all the way since the beginning of the show and now they're bringing it back because they're finally
Paying off John's Targaryen heritage that Lyanna Stark is his mother. So even though it's a really cool Easter egg for the pilot
It's actually a much bigger easter egg for everything that's going on in general. But as John walks past his mother's monument
You hear the Lyanna stark voiceover promise me?
You have to protect him the promise that she extracted from Ned Stark when he was born
he pauses and turns around like he hears something as if he's hearing her through time and space like obviously bran can do that for
Real but we don't know the circumstances of house Samwell and brand are gonna reveal that information to him
But him turning around here is Justin foreshadowing him finding out about his true heritage Santa walks past Catelyn Stark's statue
And there's this line of dialogue
If you don't remember when she gave this speech this is from her conversation with Talisa in season 3 episode 2 dark wings dark words
When she's talking about her children in how badly she regrets treating Jon Snow like crap his whole life
She talks about all the whore this come to her family the war of the five kings the death of Ned Stark
Bran, getting pushed out the window Theon sacking Winterfell
Like basically the worst possible things imaginable
happening to all of her children least to say Sansa who was stuck in King's Landing at the mercy of
Joffrey and the Lannisters
so this is mostly a speech teeing up Ned Stark's speech that we get a little bit later in the teaser where she's basically saying
That I should have loved him more like he's part of our family
Even though he might be a bastard because remember she had no idea of his true heritage
You see Arya
Finally walking through the crypts wall this Catelyn Stark voiceover talking about Jon Snow is happening and it really becomes more of them
Foreshadowing the other stark children learning Jon's true heritage in how it's going to affect their familiar relationship as Starks
Is he going to be a stark of Winterfell? Are they gonna treat him like a Targaryen?
I've already done a couple videos talking about Arya Stark during season eight and her history with Jon Snow
He's one of the few other stark children that she was close to growing up
So their reunion is obviously gonna be a really big moment
of all the Starks
I think that she'll probably be the least affected by this big knowledge bomb that brands going to drop on them
but then they cut to John walking past Ned Stark's statue and it's the speech that Ned gave him before he wrote off to the
Wall in season 1 episode 2 you might not have my name, but you're a stark
You have my blood which is technically true the next time we meet, we'll talk about your mother
So technically if he comes back to the crypts of Winterfell
They will probably be talking about Lyanna stark after he finds out so they will find a roundabout way to pay off that
Moment even though technically Ned Stark is dead
He'll be standing near his statue in the crypts
But the way they cut the speech is they're all coming together is really paying more reference to the lone wolf dies the pack survives
Speech that we got for all the season seven teasers
like even though we had all that Arya Sansa drama during season seven that was
Mostly meant to catalyze that lone wolf dies pack survives. So that was kind of the thing
They were trying to pay off with their arc
And obviously that's still very important this season only now
It's more focused on Jon Snow his heritage in the fact that they all might die
So that's sort of the way they end the teaser
There's really WTF reaction where they turn around is if they're seeing visions of their death like all of their statues in the crypts
So even though we have lots of death predictions to talk about I'm sure I'll do a video about that
Sometime before the season starts
This is just HBO raising the question like we all might die because just as they turn around the winds of winter
Blow out John's torch and then the ice starts to cover the tropical bird feather that was on lyanna stark's statue
Obviously just teasing the coming of the night king in his army. They all start to draw their swords. John draws, Longclaw
Arya draws needle, but you also see the Valyrian dagger on her hip there
So she will be fighting with that but needle is her primary weapon
I would not be surprised if they find a way to pay off
Stick them with the pointy end when she and John are sharing some scenes together before some big battle like as they write off you
Hear him say it again. Don't forget stake the White Walkers with the pointy end, although technically
She'd want to stick them with the pointy end of the Valyrian dagger
but the other big reason that you all probably
Detected that we're having this
Winterfell teaser is the first big one is because that's where the first big battle with the night
King is gonna take place in the White Walkers
Now obviously he has to wind his way down with the army of the Dead through the last whore in the Karstarks our IP
Say your goodbyes to them if they're not all still holed up at Winterfell
They're probably actually still people that live up there. But I think the idea is that most of the armies are massing at Winterfell
So they're probably not that many able-bodied soldiers left at those castles. So it's not nearly as bad as it could be
I know you're all probably disappointed that there's no ghost in this teaser. I think they were trying to do something
That was the least spoilery option that they had and it's really expensive to do the special effects for ghosts
He is a part of the season ghosts will be coming back during season eight. He's at Winterfell right now
There was a deleted scene from season
seven where Jon is leaving to go treat with Daenerys and try to form the Alliance where he says goodbye to ghost they have a
Really nice scene they wrote it. They shot it it was all good to go
But at the last minute they had to cut it for time
They just decided not to include it, but don't worry final season ghost
One of the few direwolves along with Nymeria that are still alive, obviously
He'll be a big part of the battle against the night king
so that's why the
Episodes are so big and they spend so much money on it so that they could pay off all those big things and we wouldn't
Have to go another season asking. Hey, wait a minute. They're up at Winterfell walking around ghost. Never leaves Jon's side
Where is he right now? Why isn't he in frame?
So do not be surprised if you see him pop up during that next big trailer that they released which might be February early March
But obviously there's so many other characters so many other storylines to pay off
We'll see all that stuff when they start dropping proper trailers, so we'll get more with Daenerys
We'll learn more about the dynamic between her and the people at Winterfell. We've already got a little teaser for that
We haven't seen anything of Cersei the golden company. You're on Greyjoy or anyone at King's Landing yet
That'll also probably be in that first trailer
We don't really know exactly what their marketing campaign is gonna be like so I don't know if they're gonna try and break this up
Into different camps and release separate teasers or if it'll just be another proper trailer the next time we actually get footage
but the real big news is that the premiere is
happening April 14th way earlier than I thought I didn't think it was gonna be till like the week after that at the earliest because
What happened is the reason why we're getting it earlier?
Which is great is because they're doubling up on episodes of true detective in probably big little lies
So I can't remember the last time HBO did that but I think they all sense that everybody wants the season as fast as possible
It'll be one episode per week for six episodes. Just a reminder
Some people are still surprised that they're only doing six episodes what'll happen
There'll be more promos more trailers all kinds of EPK and footage that they'll be dropping. So I'll do videos for everything
Leave all your requests in the comments below
And what I might do is I might do a Q&A video sometime next week for the trailer
So if you have any specific questions that you want me to include on that just let me know in the comments
But click here to rewatch that opening scene of Jon's Daenerys arriving at Winterfell from Game of Thrones season 8 episode
1 and click here for all my other Game of Thrones season 8 promos. Thank you so much for watching. Everybody. Stay awesome
I'll see you guys tonight